[Musique]
on commence à médan ou la maison zola et
le musée dédié à l affaire dreyfus a
ouvert ses portes aux visiteurs ce jeudi
28 octobre après dix années de travaux
la maison où l'écrivain de j'accuse a
écrit une grande partie de son oeuvre a
retrouvé ses allures d'époque après plus
de dix ans de rénovation plusieurs
champions de natation présent lundi pour
apprendre aux jeunes de poissy a nagé
dans le cadre de l'opération nageurs et
citoyens parrainé par yannick agnel les
athlètes veulent lutter contre les
noyades 259 jeunes issus de zones
sensibles ont répondu présents dans le
cadre d'octobre rose une opération a été
menée ce mercredi 27 dans le quartier du
val hibou à plaisir pour sensibiliser et
dépister gratuitement les femmes qui le
souhaitaient un même bus étaient
présents pour dépister sans rendez vous
depuis quelques jours un supermarché
anti gaspillage et à prix bas a ouvert
ses portes à maurepas les deux jeunes
entrepreneurs à sa tête ont comme
objectif de valoriser des produits
exclus de la grande distribution et puis
enfin ça y est les 70 cadets ont
effectué leur première semaine de stage
au camp militaire de ben ces jeunes de
17 à 21 ans ont fait leurs premiers pas
dans le monde militaire au programme
apprentissage du tir du champ de peloton
ou encore de la marche de nuit
[Musique]